you're you're hosting the Spirit Awards
now second time I mentioned this is
absolutely yeah pretty wild man yeah but
you know you know we haven't we want you
to know Conan we haven't changed at all
since last year's yeah yeah you know we
came in and we hosted and to us it was
just one of those days but to all of you
it was the greatest thing that ever
happened and we know that everyone you
know I remember you I don't remember you
specifically but I think you loved it
and everyone was saying how great it
wasn't to us it was like you know that's
just a day we haven't changed yeah and
we're just the same guys we've always
been okay listen let's let's talk about
this first of all you've been on the
show before this is not how you normally
drip yes you can see yes I can 20
there's wonderful people here do they
see the camera there the monitor there I
don't know no they don't see the monitor
there we that's wild man guys you must
pinch yourself man yeah yeah yeah guys
you don't normally dress this way the
show this is what you normally wear you
wear suits on the program this is what
you were wearing last time you were here
that was a long time ago that was yeah I
was 30 40 30 years ago yeah man that was
and we don't even you know it's like
we've always dressed with this sort of
steampunk meets pirate thing that never
existed in real time but steampunk meets
pirate pirate tell us about these
outfits it's steampunk it's what I know
I'm you know we're done doing comedy
we're sort of doing our own clothing now
so I'm mainly doing scarves and these
are made from real materials yeah
does that mean real materials what does
that mean this was a rap that a
wonderful Armenian woman was wearing and
in Glendale and and it's now in my back
pocket yeah and these rings these
symbolize metal yeah and we uh we own a
great pop-up shop on Melrose we doing
our clothes you got to come down there's
no parking pop up shallow but we're
doing all those shoes that look like if
a pilgrim had sex with a genie yeah yeah
you know we we recently I started doing
Decker at home decorating and we did
Gerard Butler's home recently and he was
out of town and unaware but we did gain
access through a friend of ours that is
a contractor decorated in his home
without him knowing yeah I see yeah sort
of a gothic erotica yeah and we found
this amazing piece of art it was a sort
of a black lit Jimi Hendrix poster found
in this little place all posters calm
yeah tell us about the Hat here what's
going on floppy hats now because why
should women be the only ones who can
wear hats like this and even though
they're based on men's hats you know
it's sort of a tip of the hat as you
might say to the Mad Men era you know
those days have come and gone you being
such a dick right now when when you when
you break through fear right we all know
this you realize that we're not even
here right so we don't exist yeah are we
here at all Conan are you even there
no I'm here I'm here right now
I'm here I can see both of you very
clearly yeah but are you though and can
you and are we even here are we just
atoms twirling around this tectonic
shift am i day means nothing but you say
thank you I feel very blessed you said
that I'm just a thing I'm just a thing
called John Mulaney it doesn't mean I'm
not this is just a collection of bits of
you know skin and this is a little
chubby here but this is not a person you
know I am an addict that is true I am a
you're an addict but I'm in recovery
right now I mean a recovery based on the
writings of Jose Canseco it's not a
regular AAA which is a wonderful group
this is a new group we're public denial
is key yeah and private denial is
encouraged we're sober as well and yeah
we'll just snort a few lines of lunesta
and we're sober except for a painkiller
thing that we tell no one about what you
just did did oh you just lost I'm sorry
hey no let it be by war why should
ladies have the floppy okay I'm gonna
get a straight answer out of them if it
if it is the end of me we'll take a
break more with Nick Kroll and John
Mulaney
you